on this episode we bring the ruckus on
floor 15
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Guerry be hello everybody in this is
episode 146 of the askgaryvee show sorry
guys I'm on floor 15 I feel like we woke
up the floor a little bit feels nice
India let's get into the show is that
true
you've given up okay guys Aaron asks you
mentioned how great you are at closing
in sales
what's your structure for your pitches
for my pitches so my structure for my
pitches is complete and utter no
structure
I don't really structure my pitches a
whole lot my team a in certain scenarios
have a deck but there's some sure an
inside joke in this company that when we
go into that meeting I'm in a completely
side rail and drive over that deck which
I do consistently for me I'm much more
interested in reading the room and
deploying what that client wants at that
exact moment
versus what we thought they wanted in
the same way I sold that baseball card
shows like I would just always react I'd
really think that my pitches are
structured for counterpunching which
means no preparation for presentation
form but complete and utter presentation
for knowing the content see what I mean
this is the thing that most people don't
understand they think that you wing it
know you're winning the way you're gonna
present it
you're not winging what you actually
know about it what so the way I prepare
prepare is holistically prepared aka
know my [ __ ] I know what I'm talking
about in the things that I'm selling and
then basically I'm reverse engineering
deploying your needs
against that expertise at that moment
versus what order the deck needs to be
for in the presentation my friends the
deck doesn't sell it the presentation
doesn't sell it the skills sell it
Jeremy asks Gary why do you feel the
need to swear to make a point
Sherly business credibility is better
built without swearing you were excited
about asking this question I don't feel
like I need to swear to make a point I
also don't agree that business
credibility is lost when you curse
business credibility is lost when you
curse
the judge of your credibility is a D or
F player and somebody that is making
surface-level decisions as a matter of
fact I would argue that at times I use
my cursing as a filter to filter out the
people that are not capable of seeing
the bigger picture versus being so
blocked oh my god I heard the word I
can't hear anything else everything else
must be bad there's no good advice as a
bad person that is ludicrous it goes
into the same context as the way you
dress or a million other variables of
waste people that will judge you see
when you're great you could dress in all
red all red thanks um I mean you can you
can blend into phone booths I mean you
you uh you can dress how you want you
can talk how you want because at the end
of the day the way you deliver is uh is
all that people really care about and
the way you make them feel I'm not
cursing to disrespect someone and I have
empathy and respect why a lot of people
may not like me or consume me there are
plenty people that don't watch this
video because they saw a keynote where I
cursed and they were offended and they
are no longer am I said surely I would
have a bigger audience if I didn't curse
that is absolutely true and business
respect sure I may lose out on a deal
because they were offended but then the
net net net net score I win so many more
by being me and just being me versus
creating a half version of me for the
one conservative person and leaving the
hundreds of magic business opportunities
that are predicated on winners making
decisions so yeah I'm completely in
disagreement with you and and I don't
believe that either one of us are
successful because of our cursing or non
cursing I think it has a lot more to do
with a lot of things that matter a hell
of a lot more than some choice
four-letter words
Charice what is this it's a doll it's a
baby be swaddled it he be swallowed it
with it with a napkin yeah amazing cool
sorry go ahead
spooky a [ __ ] a weird I cursed turn off
the show
go ahead Charisse asks you talk about
the importance of HR and employees
getting along how do i implement that
when everyone talks about everyone
I don't know if employees getting along
or HR is predicated on everybody talking
about each other Oh talking about each
other like gossip everyone talks about
everyone oh geez
I mean well that means it's broken from
the top like I mean people gonna gossip
I'm sure you know in the 600 employ 550
employees of vaynermedia I'm sure people
talk about each other but it's a net net
score don't be crippled by if make sure
you're judging the gossiping
appropriately maybe maybe it's not as
bad as you think in the collective right
be careful this is a an active shooter
ayan yeah yeah clearly didn't realize
I'm just kidding do you want to come on
and apologize the show get over here
right let's get you seven Twitter
followers
guy'll gone wild I'm sorry for ruining
show seguir vaynernation
dear vaynernation i sincerely apologize
for being the chef and preacher Gary
hates me now no no I love you oh well
thank tell them what football team you
like the New York Jets my boy get out
here
alright lunch back very good yeah
alright we need to come to 15 more often
there's some good action going on here
creating a culture where people
gossiping negatively about each other is
devastating there's a lot more to fix
the leadership needs to be looked at
maybe you're the leader you need to
really look at yourself I think the only
way to fix a real burning building if
it's really you know rampant and
negative is to call an all-hands on
meeting and go straight Kumbaya it's all
communication it's put it out on the
table its address it head-on
and move forward and so one make sure
you're judging it properly because in
the scheme of things humans are humans
you can't it's not like I mean veiners
great culture but like I just pull out
of micro level there's a million little
bad things going on it's just you have
to look at it as a collective you can't
turn people into robots and not make
them have all the emotions humans have
but way more importantly way more
importantly to me is if it is rampant
the only way to fix a complete storm of
this is to bring everybody together be
the leader needs to put on starting with
them I've clearly screwed up let's talk
about this probably make some firing
decisions because there's probably some
cancer cells in there it's a real
aggressive you need to address it truth
is so many of you do not want to address
it or don't know how or don't have the
stomach to that's the bigger issue and
that and I went for the dramatic kind of
moment there you know what kicking a
little bit of soft music here for that
part this is the important thing are you
willing to address it do you have the
appetite to deal with that kind of
confrontation at the global scale
that's the friction point the leaders
don't want to step up and actually be
leaders
right David with the video hey Gary its
David Shaheen husband and manager of
recording on his Amanda Vernon she's
about to sing the national anthem here
at Lambeau Field for Monday Night
Football
oh she's got to go out a little bit here
[Applause]
so I was wondering if you could give any
tips on how to capitalize on this
exposure thank you
that's fantastic I would immediately by
the google adword national anthem
singing the national anthem I would own
I would buy all the longtail words on
search on Google for national anthem
singing the national anthem national
anthem national anthem at halftime how
do I get picked to sing the national
anthem that's a long tail and I would
have your video embedded somewhere with
a story about her so create a landing
page on tumblr rebel Mouse where it
doesn't cost you a lot where you don't
have to design embed the video tell a
story about her and all her work and and
buy keywords on social around that I
would also buy Facebook ads against
Green Bay Packer fans fans of the Green
Bay Packers and say do you want to see
the video or do you want to meet the
person that she sang the national anthem
last Monday night some of them will as
well those would be the two
black-and-white executional things that
I would do that was good some real
advice some real advice Pam that's some
real advice thank you
good Charles asks do you see your
reliance on the Jets with regards to
their effect on your mood as a strength
or weakness and they're really picking
some doozies do I do I
do I see the Jets impacting me so much
on a Monday as a strength or weakness a
strength means that I'm emotionally in
tune with myself which I deploy in other
places see this is the whole you know
I'm gonna actually turning this question
into a really good question the
disproportionate amount of you who are
not winning as much and I'm not trying
to saying I love you guys but I believe
that a lot of the people that are
watching this right now that are not
winning back to the curstyn question are
looking at things too much in a micro
level you look at like and and people
assume and a lot of people leave oh
that's a weakness you're wasting a half
a day or a day or not as efficient as
you can on a Monday I view it at a much
higher level of if I'm capable of caring
about something so much and allowing it
to affect my mood that means that my
emotional intelligence is that at such a
high level that those are some of the
strengths that allow me to do all the
things that I do and have the intuition
around how people feel about things
hence the HR question hence the culture
hence the business success hence where
consumers are going with their feelings
my feelings skills are I'm proud that I
cry I cry I cry I went to Hamilton there
was a part in the play that I was almost
crying I cry all the time like when the
lion King's dad died Lion King I was on
a date in high school and I cried do you
know when piss that is like that's like
the anti pammi like that
yeah beaches and steel magnolias I cried
like a waterfall like so those are
feelings those are my strengths I see it
as a strength that's thanks for watching
show looking for some statements
appreciate you guys enjoying this 15
brought some really good stuff and blend
it into a you know I blend it into a you
know you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]